[Music]
hey jake
can i get a large bottle of that baiju
you know what
make it too large how can you drink like
that
i used to complain that every day felt
the same and now every day is the same
hey i have died 144 times
and every day ends like this but it
doesn't matter
not when you've lost everything you've
loved
renter man who's had me killed 150 times
the power to rewrite history is mine
heads up i know everything that's gonna
happen
one thing that never changes what's up
pretty boy
a bunch of [ __ ] are killing me for
reasons that remain a mystery
i am guanyin and guanine have done this
i'm trying to cry
[Music]
it's for you roy can you hear me you
can't explain it right now but i'm gonna
need your help gemma
the only woman i've ever loved and who
can stop this is still alive
i have to get killed hi roy over and
over again
until i save her i need to learn how to
fight with a sword
i would only have a day i think we can
get a lot done in a day
[Music]
someone's been the busiest little beaver
exactly
bring them all
i can do this all day
[Music]
[Music]
you